avec vos julien scheid à ce matin
bonjour julien bonjour à la une de la
presse ce matin sa nouvelle sanction qui
vont qui devrait toucher la russie après
la découverte macabre de butch à une
presse qui s'interroge aussi sur le
bien-fondé julien de ces nouvelles
sanctions effectivement avec cette
question posée par le parisien comment
taper vraiment plus fort car après les
oligarques après le système financier
bien c'est ce qu'est ce qui peut faire
plier davantage de vladimir poutine pour
arrêter cette guerre en ukraine et bien
pour le journal la réponse est simple il
faut taper je cite sur l'économie
surtout sur l'énergie tant que les
sanctions ne porteront pas directement
sur l'énergie c'est écrit le journal
l'économie russe sera gêné mais pas
désorganiser alors oui se passer du
pétrole du gaz et du charbon russe
aurait des conséquences extrêmement
défavorable pour certaines économies
européennes mais il faut dit journal que
les arrangements avec la barbarie
poutinienne justin je cite cesse c'est
peut-être cela le prix à payer pour la
paix et sur d'éventuelles sanctions
contre le charbon rue cela on y
reviendra dans l'info aequo avec l'inra
faille dans la presse anglophone julien
on apprend ce matin que parmi les
personnes visées par les sanctions
prises jusqu'ici il y à des personnes
qui appartiennent au cercle très intime
du président il n'est pas n'importe qui
puisqu'il s'agit de ses deux filles dont
on ne sait presque rien on voit ici le
président une du guardian avec sa
famille donc ses deux filles à la fin
des années 80 et son ex-femme le mystère
de ses deux filles est telle que les
russes le peuple russe jusqu'à présent
on ne connaissait que leur prénom elle
ne s'appelle pas officiellement poutine
le président russe a toujours évoqué
refusé d'évoquer sa vie privée
officiellement pour protéger sa famille
le wall street journal lui va plus loin
en publiant les noms et les photos plus
récentes des deux femmes âgés de 36 et
37 ans d'après le trésor américain
travaillerait dans des sociétés de
technologie ou de recherche scientifique
et serait surtout financé par le kremlin
au-delà du symbole pourquoi cibler la
famille du président russe et bien
d'après un responsable américain car le
président poutine aurait caché une
partie sa fortune au sein de sa famille
pour éviter les sanctions occidentales
et viser la famille c'est donc je cite
vie et le portefeuille sur le terrain en
ukraine on en parlait dans le journal
avec pauline godard après son retrait de
la région de kiev l'armée russe prépare
donc l'offensive sur la région du
dombass effectivement le journal
espagnol el país fait sa une sur cet
appel lancé par le président des dden
ski aux ukrainiens vivant dans l'est du
pays de quitter cette région dès à
présent à cause effectivement de cette
opération militaire russe qui serait en
train de se préparer dans le donbass
notamment on voit aussi des centaines
voire des milliers de personnes qui
espèrent pouvoir prendre un train akram
à tort ce que ville tout proche de la
ligne de front et surtout villes visées
par des bombardements russes ces
derniers jours et dont une partie du
chemin de fer a été détruit on prend la
direction change de sujet pardon de
ouagadougou où le procès pour
l'assassinât de thomas sankara a rendu
son verdict on y est largement revenue
hier sur l'antenne de france 24 on va
l'humanité parlé d'un verdict historique
qui rend justice à l'icône du burkina
faso tué par balle lors du putsch de
1987 parmi les trois principaux accusés
l'ancien président et compagnon de
blaise compte de 200 cars à blaise
compaore qui a été condamné à la prison
à perpétuité par contumace mais elle
malgré cela dit le journal des zones
d'ombré persistent notamment sur
d'éventuelles complicités de l'étranger
dans cette affaire la justice burkinabè
s'est notamment intéressé au rôle joué
par la france durant cette période et
malgré les promesses des manuels macron
les masses de documents transmises par
la france ne réussit guère brillé par
leur pertinence pour la presse burkinabè
il a évidemment de la frustration car
toutes les questions n'ont pas obtenu de
réponse mais après les tensions place à
la réconciliation écrit le quotidien
aujourd'hui au faso mais sous quelle
forme s'interroge le journal après le
rendu d'une justice dit-il équitable il
ne faudrait pas que les condamnés
bénéficient désormais d'une loi
d'amnistié ou d'une grâce présidentielle
au motif de vouloir stabiliser un pays
fragilisé par le politiquement par un
récent coups des tacles justice toujours
mais ici en france la famille de samuel
pâtissent professeur d'histoire-géo
décapité en octobre 2020 par un
terroriste islamiste et bien sa famille
porte plainte contre l'état français
effectivement que s'est il passé au sein
des ministères pourquoi les services de
l'éducation nationale n'ont pas pris au
sérieux les menaces qui pesé sur le
professeur de conflans sainte honorine
autant de questions posées par les
parents et les soeur de samuel pâtit qui
ont décidé de poser plein de déposer
plainte contre x e contre les ministères
de l'intérieur de l'éducation nationale
le parisien revient sur les ratés du
racing de renseignement français
notamment dit il sur la sous-estimation
du danger et des menaces proférées
contre le professeur après qu'il a je
rappelle montré des caricatures de
mahomet lors d'un cours dans libération
les deux soeurs du professeur témoigne
ensemble pour la première fois depuis le
drame et évidemment les questions sans
réponse et la colère -sous les ratés de
l'état il ya aussi ce quotidien qu'elle
essaye de elle parle de notamment de
surville en dur dit elle distel la
douleur et puis il ya ce sentiment
d'injustice l'une d'elles dit mon frère
ne s'est pas sacrifier il a été sacrifié
par tout ce qui aurait dû le protéger
avant de vous quitter cette nouvelle
tombée du ciel en angleterre à quelques
jours des fêtes catholiques de fête
chrétienne de pâques mais on ne parle
pas de chocolat non c'est le genre de
cadeau rêvé par tous les historiens
figurez vous qu'au milieu de la
bibliothèque de cambridge en angleterre
inemployées a trouvé une petite boîte
posée sur le sol avec à l'intérieur de
carnet manuscrit ayant appartenu à
charles darwin le naturaliste très connu
et qui est carnet qui avaient notamment
disparu depuis 22 ans on y trouve
notamment vous le voyez ici juste en
esquisse dans l'arbre de la vie qui est
en quelque sorte le prémice de la
théorie de l'évolution que le
naturaliste établir à 20 ans plus tard
alors on ne sait pas qui est le
mystérieux destinataires de ce colis il
y avait juste sur l' enveloppe cette
petite inscription joyeuse pâques
bibliothèque x merci beaucoup julien